and we are
live
thank you guys for joining us tonight
for another episode around the campfire
i've got to my co-host thai guy travis
cognito is out on a very important
meeting
oh i'm literally joking i have no idea
what he's doing i'm just giving you a
hard time but yeah very important
meeting for very important things so he
could not make it this evening but he
will be back next week of course uh but
travis man how you doing what have you
been up to
i'm doing well i've been
still face down reviewing xenoblade
chronicles 3 working on another game
called roller drum a preview for that as
well so
doing a lot of work been very busy just
playing games and grinding have not
gotten to do much destiny this week
actually because my deadline is
approaching but uh i was planning on
doing a ton of uh iron banner this week
so i can get that
iron lord
we gotta get the title i don't know i
was gonna say i gotta get the title
because cogs all like where's your title
it's like i have 12 other titles where's
your other titles but now i gotta get
iron lord to make sure i have that one
yeah so uh i i don't know if i'm gonna
have time to do that but uh i do want to
do it because uh
i
i just i haven't played a lot of
crucible this i don't know if am i going
to be one of those guys where i'm
working on reviews and coverage so often
that i don't get to play the games i
want to play i'm just are you turning
into are you what are you turning into
destin is this like the is this the
curse of ign uh maybe it's just a blip i
i don't know it's not very often i i
review uh games that are 150 hours plus
but yeah dude it's so hectic so um yeah
um well me i've been uh i finished up
tunic that game is fantastic by the way
that game is like
very rarely does a little cute isometric
game
like challenge you with some like
interesting little puzzles i mean i had
to look up guides for certain points
because i was like i was trying to
finish it but i did pretty well though i
think i got all but like five pages of
the instruction booklet which if you
play it you'll know what i mean
so i got almost to the final ending and
then i went to go find the other pages
had to go find a couple other things and
i got the real ending but tunic is just
a fun i don't think tunic is on switch i
think it's
game pass
uh and xbox i believe i don't know if
it's on a lot of other i know it's
coming to playstation in the fall
yeah i think it's coming to playstation
sometime in the f in the fall but
i played on game pass for pc and it's
just it was a fantastic little game uh i
also rolled credits on neon white
um so kind of did both of those in
succession neon white is like a
speedrunner's dream if you just want to
get lost trying to like shave off
milliseconds of time like i know some
people could get insanely lost in that
one i was happy to roll credits i think
i got the platinum
time and they give you like a hint when
you get to gold and that'll kind of help
you get to platinum but then i could be
like oh what's somebody do on this level
and they're like five seconds faster
than me on a 22nd level in the first
place
so yeah there are some some crazy people
in that game it's it's a ton of fun you
can i mean you can play like a 20-second
level here and there and it's like short
little burst if you want it so if you
need something to fill little gaps it
works really well
but before we get into the world of what
destiny has been up to we have a special
guest joining us all the way over from
hawaii so
welcome to the last word episode number
206
iron banner is in its final round of two
this season solstice will begin
next week and the heat is in full swing
for at least one of us
it's gonna be a fun episode tonight
because there is
mention of currencies in the twab so i
can't wait to hear what travis has to
say about that but before we get to that
we have a special guest joining us
tonight and taking time away from his
leave just to chat with us this man has
been gaming for about as long as i have
and started on that 8-bit console many
of us began our gaming journey on long
ago seriously though a zelda and metroid
flan you know you're in good company
you know gaming has been a key part of
this man's life if he still continues it
on breaks from serving our country
now we can forgive this man for being a
warlock tonight because our co-host
can't be here so he can fill in the role
of controller floofer any man who makes
sure to get a thousand kills with each
weapon before he even sits down to
writer of you plays this game in a
different way whether it's the
analytical approach that comes from
spending time with any specific armament
or just knowing his own mind
oh knowing on his own that he
did more than just look at the perk
options and knows his opinion on the
weapon comes from a place of true
honesty it's a great thing to see so
let's welcome a man with a true knack
for finding out how off meta really
feels
got a bit of the stasis bug and can't
leave shade binder alone
and a man who really made it
made it in the world of the internet
because he finally has haters too
but in all seriousness i want to thank
this sergeant first class for his
service and glad to see he will be
coming home to the city of blues and
arches after being away for a very long
time let's give it up for the one the
only crit buff how you doing tonight sir
i'm well bonded and thank you for that
amazing intro and also thank you both
travis about this for having me on the
show and thank you both for your support
um for the service and the service
members it does mean the world and it it
helps us do what we do so
uh now truly i appreciate being invited
onto the show today and uh i love that
last part of having finally acquired
some haters that's when you knew you
really made it so i mean
just ask travis about his mini reviews
and uh the comments in the ign comment
feeder
definitely something to skip over i
don't know if they're travis haters
they're more ign haters that are i'm
writing on the coattails of but yeah
i'll take it i'll take it well okay
we'll have a different discussion when
you publish your xenophage review how's
that
not zero phase
i've been using that gun too much that's
my own fault
that's true yeah you have a good point
there are people who hate me
specifically uh they're they're not as
not as many as probably craig or you but
yeah
but no that was kind of one thing i
actually wanted to ask you about is
i know your gaming journey like zelda
metroid love the fact that you love
those 8-bit nintendo fantastic but as a
military man yourself
still
making content on destiny playing enough
you know getting the thousand kills
before you publish a weapon
how has gaming been a piece of your life
all through like growing up and then
through nearly 20 years in the military
i mean what has gaming been
for you during that entire time
i think you so growing up it not being
you know terribly athletically gifted in
any specific way i played soccer for a
few years
um it was
it was a hobby it was something i could
do with my spare time it was something i
could develop to getting better at it
was
something i could take in at my own pace
and that's something i'm sure that we
probably all appreciate about the hobby
if if nothing else i think we can all
find common ground there
and so continuing on with that in the
military there are several games that
have got me through deployments so
elder scrolls oblivion
got me through my second iraq deployment
but for my first one and please
don't be too hard on me for this
dead or alive extreme beach volleyball
no3 to
204.
was
was
was there for me uh when i was in you
know just stationed just outside of
fallujah uh at fob mercury
so
you know that and then halo
the original halo
getting back stateside playing you know
the sequels
and then
of course going to afghanistan skyrim
did a lot for me just helping me get
through
that deployment because there was so
much to do and that one was a little bit
shorter deployment i was
a little bit busier than i had been
previously
the other deployments and then so uh now
having been garrison side for quite a
few years as i near the uh the twilight
of my career i'm actually in it
for the military i would say
having picked up destiny and um
wanting to
not
uh wanting to share information that i
think the average person could relate to
the best of the best player base wise i
already know what works for them already
know the meta and the
they play a court in accordance with
their play style but
a lot of us um a lot of people identify
with a certain weapon like uh irl titan
gloves
justin justin is great
justin is you know if yotan was a human
being it's justin yeah and so
we
a lot of players have those off meta
picks that they enjoy and so that's
usually why i do the weapons that i do
if they somebody already knows that they
like pulse rifles or not but when they
watch my video i'm hoping to either
reaffirm what they might like about what
they suspect they might like about this
pulse rifle or they may say oh you know
what he mentioned that one thing and
that's something that's a deal breaker
for me in pulse rifles so he saved me
the time there
a lot of people
misinterpreted
my
statement in the community focus i'm not
telling you what you should use i'm
telling you what happened while i used
it yeah
that's i mean if you actually take a
second and watch one of your your
reviews everyone you mean you take the
time to get a thousand kills with it so
you actually spent time with it because
anybody can look up
you know a gun on a
website or whatever and say these perks
are probably going to be good but
everything has different feels
you cool guy
i mean especially like the way you spend
time with a weapon you see the gameplay
you got the kills you got the footage of
you going through it's like i watch the
one with firefight with you and you're
sitting there just i swear couldn't miss
your head shots with that thing the
stability was an absolute laser
did he freeze for you
oh you're back okay
nope you're good internet caught up
um and it's just you you see you see it
in use it's not just pick it off
spreadsheet and whatever it may be i
mean that's something i'm probably to
fault for saying hey this weapon
theoretically could be good but then i
pick it up and it's like the new pulse
rifle new purpose for some reason with
me i don't
i haven't clicked with that weapon yet i
know it's got potential in that slot
it's also got adaptive munitions in that
slot
so it's kind of unique there but again
for me to like spend the time to go
after it has been weird because
one been kind of busy but two it's just
it feels off and i think that's one of
those things that
again you spend some time with a weapon
it is going to be how it feels for you
but it's if you actually you know put
hours in with a weapon thousand kills is
how many matches do you think it takes
you to get a thousand kills
so that depends on a variety of things
there are weapons that i'm naturally
just better with right i'm 40 my
reflexes are nothing
um approaching that of like a highly
skilled player you know there's that gif
out there of me shooting the ground
someone jumps over my head and then i
joke about you know aerial gameplay
being suppressed oppressive but uh so
for example firefight that took
i got 300 kills in a day on firefight
that has never happened since it has
never happened before
something about the 450 auto
works for me
um
travis could pick up firefight try it
and say it's it's garbage and for for
travis it's not the right weapon it
doesn't have trouble right yeah
there you go right so how travis
approaches encounters his
decision-making process
everything about how travis plays may
not gel well with autos but they could
work for me so that's that's the point
of the reviews now so um
submachine guns are very hard for me to
review and to do a video on because i
perform poorly with them i'm not a very
good aggressive player at all i have a
hard time tracking in close quarters
combat in addition there are just
elements of
outside of my control i'm in hawaii so i
match east asia i'm at central and south
america and that's us west coast my
connections are usually not the best
and that can also become a problem
destiny player movement can interfere
with being able to track targets in cqc
when you have reflexes like mine
so
it really is a weapon by weapon
basis
travis
um
can i ask you about dead or alive
extreme beach volleyball
you can he told me my favorite was
satomi because she told me right yes
uh when i played better a lot i played
that game
i don't remember why i think it won like
an award like best graphics or something
like that and my friend was showing it
but i actually played that game for like
eight hours one night like with my buddy
and uh
it it's one of those games where like
you for the first like two hours you're
like dude this is the weirdest game i've
ever played and then after a while you
kind of you're kind of like but i i kind
of want to see the ending for this
character or that character and you play
it for a little longer than you expected
but please tell me about your
relationship with that game and why
you're into it i need to know the story
here
so it's a catalyst right um severe
boredom plus
lack of access to anything else there
was a small shop at which was really
just someone's house that still lived on
the base we had a very strange setup
back in 03 we had occupied like a town
as our
base after it had been
abandoned mostly during the war initial
invasion there were still some families
there lived
you know right next to us and everything
and
there was a home that had been opened up
into a post exchange so you being
from a military family you understand
what a post exchange is it's basically
military walmart or target
um you don't pay taxes on anything
uh so the sticker price is the price
and the armed
uh the american armed forces exchange
service i believe that's what the
anachronism is for avs they open up
these little shops for bases uh forward
with the troops
and
they didn't have the biggest selection
in the world travis so better alive
extreme beach volleyball was a title
they felt was going to sell to a mostly
young male audience
and i can't imagine why yeah
so
and i was a fan of the fighting game i
remember playing it and i who was he
told me he had a male mentor he was he
was almost a protagonist of the series
he was a ninja with amnesia and
uh ryu hayabusa that dude
no not hayabusa his friend
his german name was i but he's actually
a ninja with it was like ryu's best
friend or brother and he had amnesia
after one of the games and he was found
in germany's black forest
oh i can't remember yeah anybody on chat
knows this game from 2003 please hit us
up
oh see i think i'm getting connection
issues with him right now
yeah we'll catch up here in just a
second yeah
he'll go super speed yep
i can't wait to hear his
explanation in five times speed it's
gonna be great yeah
i love how robert jones says doa was the
waifu game before waifus were cool
i mean true you're not wrong that that
whole that kind of started
yeah started that one up
i gotta say i love the pros
yeah yeah he looks pretty good
got that at least he didn't end with one
of these
you guys are watching the video or
listening to audio maybe it may not
always catch the video at the end of the
show when we say the last word you'll
notice we actually hold up like this two
two check marks with our hands or
whatever and for whatever reason just
like [ __ ] buff is lagged out right now
that happened to me but unfortunately it
was mid
like expression and my hands were
perfectly shaped just like this and
that's why we do that every time so it's
this weird
idiot joke that happened and now the
other two the cogs not here just make me
live with it so it's a good way to end
the show with an inside joke every time
yeah
well yeah i i also believe that by the
time you came back
from being frozen you were we were all
doing this waiting for you we were like
this
in that mode
looks like we lost him he'll probably be
back
oh cool my head my head's in an
interesting spot oh no i tried to move
this i'm trying to go back and forth to
person there we go we got him back we
got him back okay my
sincerest apologies
so we lost two options it's all good you
we had just decided who uh hitomi's
master was and you were about to tell me
what your what you thought after you
actually started playing the game
i like to tell me because i liked this
the play style of strong strikes right
so you punch someone you send them to a
wall every time so when she was
available
as a waifu that is where i naturally
and she was challenging because she she
didn't like this the skimpy suits
uh her she was a much more modest person
so yeah it's a shame when that happens
really
it's tough you gotta grind that you got
to grind the that that money do the
gambling mini game if you want to uh
careful with your word choice when we're
talking about all this stuff travis
there you go
yeah
so
okay he's a bean of a
yeah
yeah you're good now we'll see if we can
get them to blush we'll see if we can
get them turned the same color as my uh
this is great so i played that game and
then uh
i i have this um
pet peeve or if i own the original copy
of a game if a sequel comes out i feel
like i have to own it even if i didn't
like the first game just because i you
know you're making a collection here so
when dead or live extreme beach
volleyball two came out i bought it when
it was on sale for like ten dollars you
know like a six months later or whatever
after it came out
weirdly it wasn't as good it like you
fall off that game super quickly but uh
it didn't didn't capture the same magic
i guess of the original
it's just such a weird thing to say
magic but but what's funny is
i i at the time i had this thing where
if i owned a game i had to get at least
one achievement in it because that was
like proof that i played it at least
like some amount in some games that's
really easy to do in dead or live
extreme beach volleyball 2 it is not
easy you have to spend a lot of time
playing the game like there's only like
a handful of achievements and they're
all like get every costume on this
character or like you know stuff like
that where it's just like a lot of
grinding but i was committed so uh um i
was with some friends and they were like
dude you own this game and then i was
like yeah i've been trying to get an
achievement on and they were like dude
we're gonna stay here until you get an
achievement and we played way too much
of that game so i have good memories
with dead or live extremist volleyball
despite the memes and the weirdness of
that game but
uh respect man respect
i was a teenager yeah i was i was in
like early college when that game came
when the sequel came out so that means
dead or live one i must have been a high
schooler yeah a long time ago
it's like i'm a year under
you're under
our our guest but not too far since i am
officially 39 now that happened between
since the last
thank
podcast
shout out real quick to tphayden78
wanted to give a belated birthday shout
out to ibontis make sure you get that
advanced gg with cody bontes tastes
great and it works well with hashtag our
sauce love you guys
oh the earth sauce
that's kind of amazing i'm going to
create memes that follow you for the
rest of your life that's that will be
how you've got i've got podcast segments
there are hashtags now
there's going to be a clip of me some
days that turns into a gif and then i'll
know i've made it at least
that's that's how you know if you can
turn into a gift i know what like
uh greg game over gregory like i know
he's got one
that's like he's definitely got so yeah
if you if you have your own gif you've
done pretty well um
but yeah so i mean when it comes to
zelda or metroid
you gotta pick one which one do you pick
uh metroid and very specifically because
i think super metroid's set such a high
bar for what i expect from a game a good
choice
not just
yeah the zelda games are amazing for
their especially these latest titles
that focus on open world exploration and
they've always been fantastic in my
opinion uh but for metroid leaning more
to science fiction if i had to over
fantasy that's probably
the determining factor
it's not a bad yeah
i don't know travis if you get do you
even have a favoritism between those two
yeah i love both of those games um
i'm probably more zelda uh it's not that
metroid does like its genre extremely
well
it's more that just
to me it's really hard to beat like an
adventure game like zelda we're fighting
bosses and
uh doing that sort of thing and i i also
like when i played super metroid like it
changed my life i was like jesus dude
this game is so well designed and all
that stuff but uh there's something
about like the open world and you know
exploring and
you know swinging a sword at things and
riding a horse and all that stuff where
when i played ocarina of time i was just
like dude this game
this game is real also i feel like zelda
has more really good entries as a
franchise than metroid metroid can be a
little hit or miss they have some good
ones and they have some that are just
kind of mid um and i feel like zelda has
like bangers a lot so if you're talking
the entire series
probably zelda
although it's just hard to beat super
metroid as a singular game i also really
liked the uh recent one what was it
dread
it was good dress was very actually yeah
that i really enjoyed
um
yeah i mean i would probably have to
lean zelda as well ocarina is very much
like one of those
pivotal gaming moments when it's like 3d
open world on a horse going through time
it's like i hadn't really experienced
too much like that at the time
but also on the other side for me it was
like i started one of my first games was
the gold cartridge zelda
so that happened before metroid so
that's where there's like the
i wanted to play a lot of the zeldas but
as you said super metroid the missiles
trying to find every single upgrade in
that thing when you were like a kid
searching every different direction
it was
i don't know i think zelda would win but
super metroid is a very special game so
it's like it's i get i get the argument
for sure
i feel like we
feel like we lost him again yep that's
okay that's part of a hawaii kid this is
why though as he was saying when he was
talking about like an auto rifle might
work better because if it still
registers him holding the trigger in the
crystal match at least he has a chance
to still be firing
so also maybe maybe he'll be one of
those people you know some people retire
and move to hawaii
maybe he'll retire and move away from
hawaii and that'll be his treat where he
can get good internet because uh
that'll be his uh his version yeah
retirement new rad said no chrono chrono
trigger is still
definitely like in a very short top list
for me if not near the like top three
for me
but i was just going between those two
do what you can
do you see ho grossed it on sunday
does he really not like that game
no he loves it but he did a uh
we did a um what
it's called it's called w3yfg uh what's
wrong with your favorite game was the
name of the
the segment and so what we did was we
took everyone's favorite games and we
just roasted them real quick
that was actually a good one so yeah he
did uh he did really a really good
segment on um on chrono trigger which is
one of his favorite games that you can
watch i think if you click on bitcast
they clipped it so you can see like a
little clip of him doing it's like 30
seconds but it's really good
i mean
the game is not perfect of course but
none are but that i don't know if they
if square ever could make like another
after you know final fantasy vii remake
part three if they ever think about
doing another one my hope would be for
that do i ever expect it because there's
so many different magical people who
came together for that game no but if
they ever could please
i don't know it's just
so many unique characters and it was
like the group attacks for me that i
always loved because you'd have the two
pairs then you'd get all three have your
certain special attacks that you do so
yeah chrono was definitely an epic one
well before we get into the destiny
stuff i definitely want to try and let
crit buff get back here
yes sir have you so you haven't played
much haven't played at all this week
have you
uh i think i played a little i logged in
uh might have done some events
i definitely haven't played since reset
that's what i mean i haven't played
yesterday i haven't gotten to do any uh
any iron banner
i was like i'm working through going
back and forth between titan and warlock
for the daily challenges so i can finish
that one but man that one
triumph
for the title
we have to do like the objectives in
riffs
objectives yeah
why is it always there's there's like
one bounty an iron banner
that would always come through it's like
three of them would go relatively the
same speed and one was always half of
that speed i'd finished three bounties
and the other one was like 50
this is like the same thing i'll be done
with every triumph multiple times over
i'll probably reset three times before
it feels like i'm gonna finish this one
and i try a decent amount i've got a
decent amount of dunks
um
there we go we're back
so one thing i'm not going to miss about
hawaii
the internet i don't i don't doubt that
that was the thing actually i was like
he will have a reverse retirement where
he instead of moving to hawaii he moves
away to somewhere he can stream better
so i apologize i think you were talking
about chrono trigger at some point i saw
a chat mentioning chrono trigger oh yeah
i just mentioned because we were going
back and forth between metroid and zelda
i think i leaned a little more zelda
um
but the new red knows
is like one of my favorite games of all
time he's like what about that i was
like what's it's up there
but yeah it's that one's special
chrono trigger i adored chrono trigger i
beat the first time and
i got to the the village at the end
where you're supposed to go talk to
everyone and see the results of what
you've done after you've defeated lavos
spoilers
uh and i think at this point you're okay
i'll give you that one
right it's only been a few decades i had
to hit pause because i had a soccer ship
as a tournament soccer championship game
to go play
before
i could find out and see what had
happened during the ending so i
literally had to hit pause and be like
well i guess i'll get back to this in
like three hours went and played the
game tied with the number one team and
then came back home you tied i thought
what about what about shoot-offs
whatever happened to shoot-offs
the championship ended in a tie no one
won this year it's fine that's insane
the presumptuous
they brought trophies
they brought trophies yes
shoot off i demand a shoot-off what is
this
so
yeah that was wow
we used to have a country what has
happened
when you don't have a shootout for your
little league soccer game
yeah
i also played in a championship little
league game and there was a shoot-off
and i lost and you know what i'll take
that l i'll take it
it was fair you're like i don't i don't
need this participation blue ribbon yeah
i would rather get second place than say
i tied for first that's insane but yeah
i digress but that's me that's crazy
what happened when you came back after
the weirdest tie ever
went around the village talked to
everyone new game plus and did that
until i got all the endings and if you
remember chrono trigger there was like
17 yeah that means there's a lot to that
it was a high number so
i just i i i got all the endings right
the one where you don't save magus or
magnus you do save them um
you don't replace colonel with the doll
you do
right uh
my favorite is the one you've done new
game plus a few times you can just have
it be chrono and marley
uh who fight lavos you go you go on the
opposite teleportation pad at the
carnival at the start and you are
immediately sent to the last boss of the
game
didn't even know that wasn't there
yeah and if you do new game plus enough
you're you with the healer and the dps
that is chrono you can
uh
you can fight lavos and beat them
and your characters kind of sit there
and go what was that about i don't know
what happened i don't know big crazy
boss we took him out we're too powerful
anyway back to the party
yeah so
well
no i think we got a solid connection
with you again so i did want to kind of
jump over to the world of destiny got a
couple things uh have you had a chance
to play iron banner this week i know i
asked travis and he hasn't had a chance
yet what about you
i did um so
a big shout out for
mudkip if you know him on twitter yep
uh
there you go so he's been doing some uh
charity fundraising for bungie ah yes
for this event yep and joined him and
his team for iron banner and it's been
fun i got my iron lord title the first
week like a madman
yep you're crazy
two of us you're like cog
it's while i was working on the uh
yeah
he had no choice it's a
man
i hope it's worth the surfing that's all
i'll say i will say when i went there
because that was our honeymoon got lucky
enough to go there for a honeymoon
i had never surfed in my life
and we stayed on maui and we went to
like you could stand out there to about
shoulder level for me a little taller
than you you might have been drowning
but i could stand out there
[Laughter]
anyway it is so funny when you rent a
surfboard i wouldn't i wouldn't have to
stand up there because i could surf yeah
swim i can swim that's fine i
could i've never learned to surf but
when you rent a surfboard like you see
always in the movies and stuff there are
these tiny cute little things
the rented surfboard is like a sidewalk
it is so big
it puts every you're just up there like
okay i don't even know how to fall off
of this thing so the little baby waves
where you could stand up managed to
actually
get uh
get up after a little while but we ended
up going like three of the mornings out
of the week we were there we like fell
in love with surfing i wish i was closer
to that that would actually be a ton of
fun
yeah so there's actually a separate word
for the mini surfboards they're not real
ones though the big the big one that you
got is a proper like real surfboard but
only the hardcore surfers own those like
people in my neighborhood do because i
live right next to the ocean but yeah
most people they just
you know if they go to like the beach
every once in a while they won't buy the
big ones because they take too much
space they'll buy those small guys
there's a name for them boogie board
thank you robert jones you got it boogie
board that's what they're called yeah
so
okay
oh no okay well okay i'm not talking
about those those are ones you can
almost like you get on your chest like i
don't know if people are standing on it
no but i'm thinking of like the movie
style surfboard to where it's um
it just it was a little it's you know
smaller than what i got i got something
i got a training board that was like
way oversized
interesting it was like a
12-foot massive piece of just inflatable
whatever so it was it was a little crazy
you're basically riding a canoe is what
you're telling me
yeah it was about that big like it was
it was definitely an experience okay
i've never seen one of those but yeah
it's good to know you got the logo back
we got the left yes so
i'm hoping that maybe just voice will
make this better i i do apologize
everyone um
i i i have no choice in service
providers where i live so this is
unfortunately the boat i'm stuck in
that's me travis has the best internet
between all of us and i normally have
the worst internet between all of us so
we'll roll with it it's all good
usa um on choice in uh in isp
is that the time for me to talk about
that
i don't know i say go for it
okay
well guys we need to break up these
pseudo monopolies called 18 t and
comcast no i'm just kidding i'm gonna
get on that soapbox although i could
i have the other one i have spectrum or
att so
yeah i'm i'm with the faster of the two
but it's all cable if i could ever get
fiber yeah i swear it's like i want to
like spearhead the like getting fiber
internet into my entire city or
something and like
put that whole project together if it's
like i swear it'd be worth it i told you
before there's a fiber line 700 like
feet from my house that's stupid how
close that is
uh if you guys can hear my dogs they are
chatting and playing right now so that's
always fun
uh but yeah iron banner this week uh
since you're back how's your experience
in iron banner been since i know you
were helping mudkip
well enough we were running a full team
so it was mostly easygoing uh you see a
lot of
the better bleed over from the more
competitive playlist naturally right
people are are using what is going to
give them the path of least resistance
to a win i cannot fault them for that
and so you're you're seeing a lot of
that and
i
i personally have kind of given up on
trying to provide my two cents on
whether or not that's for better or for
worse it it is what it is and there's
nothing i can do about it or to change
it and so i guess just besides
developing unique strategies my own to
combat it as i can
well we understand believe me we all
understand that piece of it it's just
like whatever i mean if you got a good
group that's playing well then just roll
with whatever works for you guys that's
the best that you can do i mean for me
playing by myself as a solo player
it's one of those that's always a little
a little bit sketchy but
i mean i'll use half the time i'm just
trying to get things done or get
participation so i'm not trying
especially if i'm switching between
characters right now for the challenges
if i sync up time in my titan i might go
a little harder on like picking a decent
load up but if i switch over to my
warlock i'm literally just getting like
the match completions and i'll switch
back like but it is good when you do
that to kind of use something a little a
little weird kind of break my normalcy
which is nice
yeah um what i would like to do in a
perfect world is starve
people of special but you can't really
effectively do that right because
they're just gonna spawn back in with
their the two kills that they need
and while yes um they may not able be
able to get 40 main ingredient kills a
game or lord of wolves in this case
they're still spawning back in with two
shots so
it's
still
not much that you can do to combat
except for to hopefully
make your decisions based on what you
know they're using and play around that
you know
well i mean
it feels like kind of with crucible
right now i mean i've seen
what looked like dissertations on
crucible on twitter recently so i mean
there's been there's been a lot of
feedback with the state of things people
are not happy with classy restoration
uh being a mod people would like to see
that turned off in pvp
um it helps people in pve like it
through dungeons i mean there's there's
balances to it and it's just it's weird
to see
especially with classy restoration it's
weird to see them be
open to leaving that there
when there's so much complaints but then
on the other side you know deactivate
the sidearm thing because it shoots
through
the bubble which you see like every so
often but everybody can dodge into a
classier restoration or everybody gets
that it's
it's weird to see what they will and
won't like touch
um
it's funny when i saw a classy
restoration when we when i opened up the
artifact at the start of the season and
i went over and that's usually the last
column is where all the cool stuff is i
saw that
and i said to myself like wait didn't we
learn our lesson with elemental battery
what did that one do i forgot
that one gave you an overshield when you
used like the
at least i remember it it was
i forget they would basically wear a
worm husk they would dodge they would
have an overshield while they were
dodging
and then they would get
their health back from warm husk
it was
similar
not quite exactly the same to what we're
dealing with now where you effectively
have to kill a hunter like three or four
times
what the amount of health is they can
get back yeah
i was like i mean me as a titan i'll
throw up a wall i've got laura lee i
mean that thing's pretty powerful too
hunter's warm husk crown you've got that
one
what's the the stag standing in a rift
now you get healing and damage
mitigation i mean you've got
ways on all sides of it where it's going
to be you're going to be pretty tanky
just depends on if you catch them in the
moment there are certain builds though
and the fact that
i would still say
hunters as you it's literally part of
your movement
to be able to actually keep it with you
seems like one of those things
it's yeah
but i mean hey what do we got six more
weeks of this and then we'll move on and
everybody's going to be like oh i missed
that in pve and pvp complainers and all
those things and then we'll get a new
season there only six weeks holy crap i
was
ballparking six seven weeks something
like that
dude i think i'm not even
max season rank i need to play i need to
play more death to me this season i've
fallen behind you've been you've been
busy man that's all right yeah
uh you might be one of those you might
be one of those casuals that just gets
to 100.
how dare you actually i kind of already
am i kind of stopped playing like 120
150 and then i'm like hey um
rise the iron lord
title i can get next season if i if i
end up not correct this week right okay
cool
yes
so i mean um let me ask you do
considering that we're on the subject of
iron banner gentlemen do either of you
see yourself really aiming for something
specifically from the playlist right now
that you can focus your engrams
no
not i was like a lot of them have been
there and if i wanted to roll on most of
them i think i've got a decent amount of
them that i do
uh i got a decent wisen rebuke but it is
also a nine it's like you know 960
nearly it's the slowest type and i think
i got one with
was it no backup plans maybe a
successful warm-up like it's a decent
one for a fusion rifle but
um
as it's a slow one i still don't know if
it would actually do that much that's
what i'm gonna have to experiment with
just to see if it ends up being
worthwhile but there's
i mean i just got done farming hardcore
for
what was it um the title and i actually
like a couple of my roles on the title
like the void smg and we have another
void smg and i think i was like i've got
one but when it comes to
iron banner in and of itself not really
much to farm for at this point i mean
for new players maybe but honestly when
we get to talking about the event the
new players are going to get a lot more
out of that actually
what's interesting about iron banner is
that some weapons have origin traits
like uh hero's burden having the service
origin trait right something that can be
taken and used elsewhere whereas
say forge's pledge um the machine gun
wasn't rebuked any of the
hand cannon any of the iron banner
specific weapons they just have this
gulking wolf trait and so
yeah that's it's it's so it's a tough
sell yeah
yeah they almost need to put on
to make those worthwhile i mean it is a
pvp and pve game
and as you said the suros trade would be
there but it's like
almost iron banner should have
an alternative reason to farm for those
weapons
as you're saying get a pve
option in there on those four origin
traits to give you a reason to use them
outside of there and make it kind of
cool
because then you'd have a reason to go
play because
only what is it when the fires are lit
or when you guys have the rift or
something or when you have the spark are
like the two minuscule times when you
can actually get the benefit from that
origin trade it's just very oddly
specific for that i agree
right and so i imagine that when it's
active it's powerful right being taken
off radar is always going to be powerful
that's why a lot of people play invis in
addition to on the oculus but
some incentive to use in another
playlist would be would be cool and
possibly something that could be worked
towards one day um
the only thing i would tell you is that
i suppose if you don't already have
a hero's burden with repulsor brace and
you're a really big fan of void and
repulsor brace you could do that that
could be a targeted farm for you with
your engrams
but the holster brace does drop on the
trays
yeah i'm gonna say then you get into the
debate of what's not craftable though so
my odds of getting the perks that i'm
looking for with the reputation grind is
gonna be quite a while
that's fair so what are your thoughts
i've i've seen you know back and forth a
little bit about craftables and things
of that how have you taken to being more
of a pvp player how's craftable weapons
kind of taken to your playstyle
um
it's interesting because we know or at
least correct me if i'm wrong on this
but my understanding of bungie's
philosophy is that usage rates uh
did we lose him again
i can't i can't hear you
i i saw it very excited i said it
defeated it quietly and didn't quite
come through
man where are you uncrafted since we'll
get back to his response
craftables like crap weapons i don't
think it's that like i said i think uh
you can't really get pure god rules with
crafting because they never let you get
the best perks but they let you get most
of the way there and so if you
are kind of a hardcore light like myself
like i'm not the hardcore of the
hardcore i'll play to get the five red
frames and get a craftable version of
the weapon and then grind it up a little
bit when i have time but i'm not willing
to do the same activity 50 times over
and over and over again to get a god
roll organically like i've just never
grinded for god rules because i don't
really think it's worth the squeeze yeah
and so uh
i think it's it's great where the people
who really really really want the best
equipment they can grind endgame
activities for
uh
the what are they called um
the special versions you get from my
grandmaster nightfall oh adapt adapt
adapt yeah you can get the adept weapons
with a god roll and then you have like
the best version or whatever but that's
if you want like the five percent extra
power that you get from doing that
because i think you can get like 95 of
the way there with
uh craftable weapons so i kind of like
it i think it's in a good spot it gives
good you know
the only risk they have is if they let
you craft the
best version of the weapon then you
would just be completely de-incentivized
to grind for the adepts or for the uh
the god rules that come to you
organically and i'm sure some people
would bemoan that but
i don't really i think you should be
able to get the loot once you do the
activity and
complete all of the check marks that
bungie's asking you to check off so
not that big of a fan of rng in general
yeah i mean like the raid rng needs to
have a cap on it in my personal opinion
we've discussed that before like
after 20 raids either you've been
dragged through it enough somebody knows
how to do it or you have mastered enough
that you should probably get it if
you're doing 50 60 70 80 it's ridiculous
the one thing i will say that's a little
frustrating is
um if you're going for season specific
weapons
um
it seems like
if you're going for
trying to think of an example i was
doing nightmare containment and i had
already got drank for example or sever
like if it's a seasonal mission and
that's one of those things that is
mostly going to be dropping those two
it would be nice if it kind of had a bit
of a knockout list like if you are
trying to get that last one if you do
get a red frame it is going to be for
the stuff you haven't received i think
because i mean yeah it's going to take a
while for them to drop anyway but i
think on the other side it would be nice
that because i got a drink i got drang
done i got callous mini tool i just
finished off stringer and then i just
got another drang red one i'm like oh
that's just completely wasted so it's
just that weird if you're working
towards that in one specific activity
and it doesn't drop i know like
everything can drop we had that you know
unfortunate moment for you last time but
it's just like if you're working in that
one specific place where you're trying
to grind for it
i think those should be worked through a
little bit better are you back crit
yes i am okay
at least for the moment thank you um
i can feel
the frustration
sorry no you're good
i was like we get it and so i feel bad
for you yes yeah
day to day
i would move you know my internet my
internet goes out once i start packing
boxes
um
the good news is i do have a permanent
change of station to the u.s east coast
here at the end of the month so
where are you going to be
fort knox
not that
location of uh goldfinger james bond
movie
classic classic james bond movie um
yeah uh i i think um i think that's a
good point there would be it would be
great to have a knockout list for red
frames i also think
they should make their grind less long
when when you're leveling up your
craftable weapons because i think
hunting for frames is fine but though
when you add another layer of grind like
oh you have to use the crappy version of
the weapon for 20 full levels that's
kind of crazy to me
and it also means that even once i'm
done with the 20 levels
it would behoove me to just put that
weapon in my vault and get another
crappy weapon and start grinding that
one up and so you end up never using the
weapons that you want yeah because you
always could just be using the worst
versions to you don't want to waste xp
right oh i'm gonna be doing strikes
anyway i might as well use the crappy
weapons that i need to level up and so
it it it's created a situation where i
almost never use my favorite loadout i
always have like at least one you know
crafted weapon i'm trying to rank up
while i use other ones that are i'm good
with and uh that's just that's no way to
live you pontus that's no way to live
like i have i got my callous mini tool
crafted with incandescent i have enjoyed
blowing stuff up with that quite a bit
so that one kind of stays but if it's
the top or bottom yeah it's like it is
i'm not using my pulse rifle that i
enjoyed for a while it's like what red
frame can i use and especially if you
get one then you that you've got to use
it for 20 levels unlock it all
no i fully agree it's like but it's a
point of their you know they've got
their engagement that they want to do
how long do they keep you in it and it's
all those metrics and numbers but i
would say if they could pull back
you know 20 on that it'd be nice to see
those numbers go up a little faster at
least if you're leveling up the weapon
give you a little more
just usability quicker like if you start
leaning it or if you start doing you
know almost like a streak bonus like the
longer you use the weapon the faster it
levels up especially when you get up to
you know those last few levels you're
trying to see just those last couple of
perks like you know start working
through them
um
i guess so
on the subject of weapon crafting
if i understand bungie's philosophy
correctly balance for them is not
every weapon having the same ttk doing
the same damage over all over time
balance was i think everybody not using
the same thing was the quote that i seem
to
have in my head
does that sound familiar or am i crazy i
mean it seems like it's definitely
possible at some point i mean that
sounds like something where
they want anybody to be able to use any
weapons probably is something i've heard
at some point as well it doesn't seem
out of left field
right so if that if that holds up if
that's true and i remember that quote
correctly unattributed unfortunately
then what we have is everybody using the
same piece of mind
everybody using
the same ostringer everybody using the
same beloved
and
that seems
um at odds with that philosophy if i'm
remembering that correctly
i mean we're also in the world of
destiny where it's like you know we joke
that this will never be an esport it's
never going to be completely balanced so
then on the other side i guess like how
much effort or
are they ever going to put into making
everything even if everything's even is
it boring or do they do what they do and
constantly kind of fluctuate us as we go
on the slow roller coaster of this is
good now it's not so good oh it's coming
back again oh it's going away like
is that what they're trying to do is
just constantly have this rotating
meta and off metal meta situation or do
you feel like their goal is to ever get
it truly balanced
oh i mean to get to aim for true balance
would seem to be a fool's errand
travis is over here cracking up what do
you think travis
yeah i mean i
i think that uh
it is impossible for them to balance a
game with thousands of weapons and
they're constantly adding more plus all
these different power sandboxes plus the
armor and the stats thing and yada yada
i don't think that'll ever happen but
i do think it
uh it is incumbent on them to try and
that they will always have to try as
long as multiplayer is a part of the
game uh because you can't just say well
my game is never gonna be balanced so
i'm gonna make it supremely unbalanced i
mean you could try
uh that tactic and maybe people would
laugh for a weekend like laser tag
weekend but you can't you can't make
that your entire
game design there's just no
there's no coming back from that and the
fan base would flee eventually but uh i
think um
i think they have to try to always get a
little bit closer and sometimes it is
you know one step forward and ten steps
back but uh you know as long as they
keep trying and
i feel in some ways if you look at the
overall arc we've gotten a little closer
to balance
over time um
you know come a long way ways from the
days of uh
every melee and grenade was a one one
kill you know if you did that 100 hours
of d1 so
um i think we've i think we've gotten
closer but it's it's you know it's an
ongoing process so
good on them for continuing to try
they're nowhere close now and i don't
know that they'll ever get
you know very close they might they
might get approximately as good as it's
going to get but then i don't think
they'll ever really close that gap too
much so yeah
what's that uh what's the myth of the
the man cursed to roll a rock up a
mountain
and then
falls right back down yes i think
that seems very
you know appropriate
to think about
bungie is sisyphus and uh they
they push the rock up the hill every
season and then telesto kicks it back
into their face
that is that is too expensive
alyssa's at the top of the mountain this
foot in their face so it's good times
oh
it's great i love it
banshee holding that gun it's just
well the fact that he like it broke him
just shows that that weapon is too
powerful for the game that's
i mean just despite them they've kept it
in there as long as it has at some point
it would have been like i'm sorry this
exotic has been just removed from the
game i don't care anymore just delete it
that probably would have happened at
most other developers but they still try
and keep it in
but on the outside of uh pvp if you're
enjoying iron banner this is your last
week to get it in so if you're trying to
get your title
this season at least now is the time
because it won't happen until season
18 and who knows if they're gonna do two
do you guys think they're gonna do three
iron banners next season or do you think
they're gonna just stick with their two
depends on how little content they have
next season
travis
they do have a raid next season but it
will be a reprised raid but then you
have master difficulty so
well we know that they they have as many
iron banners as they need to be able to
say that they're having something going
on in destiny every week right let's get
out the rules so
however
that's probably the
math yeah
how many weeks do we need to use it
yeah how many weeks do we have to put
say hey it's iron banner week so that we
have something to post on twitter about
what's happening this week that's uh
what seems to be the math so
well probably probably three times be my
guess yeah that'd be
my guess or hope i guess just to give
you a little more chances at the title
if you're trying to grind for it so it's
not quite as especially if you need
three if you need
to do the daily challenges you have to
do 12 of them
means you need to literally do it three
times so if you don't have another
character you literally can't get it
done in one season
so that would be my guess but if you're
not a pvp player and you don't really
love grand masters pve has been a little
late quests
all finished up and then not much going
on this week but next week we have
solstice coming back so we have the
european aerial zone returning a brand
new kind of activity for we've got the
bonfire bash i'm not entirely sure if
that's like a tower defense thing or if
it's just going to be similar we'll have
to see what that's all about but we have
the new event card that kind of gave us
a bit of an overview of that the event
card basically sounds like
what we had the books for in destiny 1
where you kind of like flip through do a
couple things and it'd show you where
everything
is gonna be for the event that kind of
consolidated so in your
quest tab you got bounties you got the
quest you're working on then it has a
little seasonal challenge bar i think
they're gonna shrink that little bar and
then put the event book right there it's
kind of the way they described it or if
you want to check it out at evo levante
you can
uh we're gonna have seals and titles so
teddy is gonna have more things to chase
now he's gonna have the solstice side
title and seal but he's also gonna have
the
multi
season events
thing that he's got to keep up with now
as well
so you're going to have two different
titles one that you can get and then one
that you can start working on but you
won't get that one completed for a whole
year
so the ocd completionists will struggle
on that one for a little while i hope
that i hope that they make some title
that's just uh
impossible for teddy to get because i
want to see how far that curse would
drag him down
uh you know like it would be like flying
back from gamescom or something
yeah you know uh you ever know um
elder scrolls online
elder scrolls online has a in-game
achievement
you can get in like an xbox live
achievement for it for being the emperor
of the game and to be the emperor of the
game means you have to have the highest
score
in the game and then like go through
some sort of political process where
like the winning faction elects you as
emperor it's like one of the rarest
achievements ever because only one
person can have it per like in game
season and it's a incredibly time
consuming and political process to get
it and
i actually found there you can find
interviews with people that talk about
like how they became emperor for a
season like how crazy it was and like
how much time and money and all that
stuff they had to do to get it and uh i
hope they come up with something like
that with triumphs where it's just like
be number one on the leaderboard and
crucible you know like first place you
have to be first place to get this
triumph uh just because i want to see
i kind of want to see what would happen
i think it would break
who did we have on we had scarole on
with teddy and then they connected over
being like triumph you know
orders and they want to have all of them
and if you ever made once where it was
like you were number one this season
yeah that whole group of triumph people
would be mad so like either they're
gonna piss off 57 of the 58 people
i don't know if they would ever go quite
that far that'd be that'd be right 57
people it doesn't mean anything in the
grand scheme of things and the people
who have every triumph you would know
they were serious because now it doesn't
really mean anything all it means now if
you tell me you have every triumph it
doesn't even really mean you're good at
the game it just means you have a lot of
time like a lot of time
you know what i mean yeah but if you
were actually number one and it was like
something where like you had to do
something crazy then i'd be like oh damn
he's got every triumph that's mad
respect but uh i don't know i mostly
just want to see uh teddy get broken as
a person that's really my goal and
always that's my stake ah true friend i
want to see what happens when he breaks
yeah let's see what happens
it would be interesting to me
so the event card's gonna have your
challenges that you gotta do over the
course of the event the seals and titles
also got the upgraded event card now
this is the free optional side of things
they covered this in a previous swab
uh basically what it is is the fact that
you're gonna have
uh they had a listing of it so if you do
the upgraded event card you've got the
hot dog eating champ you've got the
sunny exotic ghost shell you've got a
shader you've got an emote
and then
from tickets you're gonna have another
ghost hologram an exotic ship another
ghost hologram which you're not really
selling me those ghost holograms those
feel so useless most of the time
trans matter effect as well so it's
mostly cause it is basically just
cosmetics
do you feel
again we've talked about the pricing and
things of that before
where do you stand i'll start with you
crit buff of the idea of taking the
seasonal event and now adding
an upcharge for
this thing now it's probably if you went
to buy bought all the different things
from everest it would be cheaper but
where do you where do you land on the
upgraded event card yay nay don't care
let's see so we don't
my mindset on this having come from
world of warcraft a few years ago before
switching to destiny is that i don't pay
a subscription fee
and bungie
does have to make money to continue
making games
um
i'm sorry i'm going to have such a non
interesting take on this i guess i will
just say that
it doesn't directly impact me in a
negative way so i'll learn to live with
it
does that i don't know am i crazy for
that you know would you would you prefer
that those things were earnable in game
oh in a perfect world yeah you know and
ideally if if this was you know star
trek and gene roddenberry's vision of a
world where we didn't have to pay for
things like food
was a reality then of course uh next
generation
yeah exactly um
i understand the why
so
looking at it through that lens i've i
suppose i come to peace with it um not
to say that everything should cost me
you know like if weapons started costing
me five cents to loot a chest at the end
of a vanguard strike now we're like
okay okay hold on hold on
but um
yeah
travis i gotta get your take i haven't
even got to the currencies yet but just
on the upgraded event card
how we feeling about this
one i hate it
i knew that was coming
i hate it so much
it's
look i get it you're making a live
service game
the problem i have
is that you need to pick what type of
game you are and have a payment model a
monetary model that fits that game type
because right now they sell you base
expansions which is what all games do
right games with with uh no support in
games with support cellubase expansion
they have
season pass model which a lot of games
that are free make all of their money
purely off of season pass model they
have micro transactions on top of that
season pass model
and they charge for things like transmog
and now you're charging me for the
things that are in the season pass the
seasonal activities or i guess that
those are the things in the season pass
but things that are happened during the
season of the season pass it would be
like
things alone was convoluted so yeah
right right yeah it would be like if you
play if you open up apex and they were
like hey buy the season pass and then
you bought the season pass and then two
weeks out of that season pass they were
like here's a special event but this
also has like its own mini season pass
you have to pay for items that are
exclusive behind another paywall and if
they did that in apex i would i would
raise a major eyebrow but on one hand
i'd be like well i didn't really pay for
this game i paid for the season pass and
i guess this doesn't count but i would
still raise an eyebrow destiny has no
excuse they have
so many
sources of revenue and let us not forget
they just got purchased
but a large company that they they don't
even have the excuse of we're an indie
company doing things the hard way
anymore they also are are you know now
bought they
i'm sure that none of that money went to
the company it all went to their
shareholders and the people that that
started the company but still they're
they're are under papa sony they have
uh they don't even really they're not
even at the scrappy stage so for so many
reasons i have a problem with this and i
think that
somebody is super greedy over bungie on
the monetization team and they need to
just take a look at the ecosystem
if you need
to
if you need to
add this
take away something else and maybe take
away one of the things that is
preventing your players from playing
together like the expansion model that
says hey if you don't own this expansion
you can't do this activity and it
divides up playlists and do all does all
that stuff hurts the community actively
if you're gonna add something like this
at least fix one of the problems that's
being caused by your really dumb
monetary system i need you to
i need you to to
give give us a little back because it
really is starting to feel off kilter
now um and it just
why
this is another thing that players were
getting for free we used to expect that
we would get some of these items for
free and
i just uh it really bothers me man
so
no i mean honestly you have a good point
there because
you brought up the what it's like for a
new player and
i mean most games if you're gonna buy
the i mean world of warcraft couple of
us have played it you're gonna get the
newest expansion you're gonna pay for
that one and that's how you kind of jump
in
and you might get the base destiny but
you're not going to have to buy
i'm not going to have to buy cataclysm
eight years later just because it's the
old expansion but i got to make sure i
have the content to be able to go do
this one activity or say a nightfall
comes up and you can't do a nightfall
because you don't have
a specific expansion that's the type of
stuff as travis said fully agree we're
at the point where
it just feels
unnecessary but as travis said if this
is a necessity then do the other thing
and make the old expansions free because
how old are some of those getting you
still have to buy shadow keep correct
like shadow keeps not free forsaken's
gone we know that one
and it's like there's got to be a point
to where it's like some of the stuff is
going to go into the content vault are
they going to make shadow keep free in
january before the thing comes out in
like march or april so you get a few
months of it free go play it and then it
goes again but then if you buy it right
before that you could waste your money
it gets to a point to where
i i understand as you said they're
trying they were trying to make money
they're doing these things
this one just feels
like how many of these can we
can we shoehorn into the game
before we get to the point where they
get enough feedback that people are mad
and
we still have the point to wear the
season pass armor which looks very cool
feels like it also could have been in
the dungeon this time because it has
like the death armor face and kind of
the nightmare look to it and it was
another one of those moments where that
was shoved behind eververse as opposed
to in the game so
again that's a moment where why is that
not the armor that looks badass in the
dungeon
but that's in every verse but then we
turn around we also have this
foreververse to get these cosmetics that
we could earn it's just
i think travis has got a legit point
there there's just
there's there's a few too many now and
they gotta pull
somewhere to get a little bit of faith
back with the community because if you
have the backing of sony and you feel
like you're hiring
craploads of people at this point they
are hiring constantly new days so many
people got those wooden bungee swords
last week and stuff like that so much of
that stuff is going on they seem to have
the budget to be able to do what they're
doing
so at some point they got to do a little
bit back for their community that's
still here that's still trying to do
this because they're not helping the new
players get in
and if you're not helping new players
join your franchise hurting the ones
that are there are just going to thin
the herd slowly and surely by the time
you get to whatever is post destiny 2's
final shape whenever he gets a season
god what is that going to be 18 19 20.
season 27 would be the last season which
sounds insane to say that word
but season 27 when that ends and the
whole franchise this 10 year saga is
done
if you've pissed off everybody if you
just nickel and dimed us all the way to
death yep 27 like
when you try and do whatever follows
that
i don't i don't know how you do that if
you piss people off just enough that
eventually everybody's like i'm done
sorry that was a long-winded
corroboration of your answer no it makes
sense i i just
i i think this is hurting their game in
multiple ways not only because it's
confusing to the player in terms of oh
what do i have to buy just to be caught
up dude you know how many people hit me
up and go travis i've been trying to get
back into destiny or i'm trying to play
dust and get into it for the first time
what do i need to purchase to just get
it all because i thought i bought the
game but then i tried to access an
activity and it said i needed something
else and they're really confused by it
so there's that level of
uh
kind of confusion but there's also just
the confusion of like
what what are you paying for what what
parts of the game do you get by making
certain purchases and what are you
entitled to what in the game can be
earned versus what has to be purchased
and i feel like that's it's been such a
weird
slow shift into something else oh i i
don't know i'm sort of
spinning in circles we've already talked
about it i'll just say this bungie you
are primed to make a mobile game
like you're ready
have fun
your your
hats off to you man you've done all your
they're they've got the netty's money
and that cr that collaboration
right all right if that thing is
successful and i see that they make a
hundred million dollars in the first
month of their mobile game this stuff
has got to back off i swear
because that better be a cash cow pay
for your daddy's investment and come
back in here and clip the wings on a
couple of these things but yeah it's
like i know it's just cosmetics i know
it doesn't affect the game at all
but it's still a point personally to me
that i just like it just
it
it's like transmog already didn't feel
great that you could technically buy
some of that stuff to speed up the
process and i'm like okay it's still
cosmetics and i know this is still
cosmetic but this is the weird one for
me and i don't know why this one's like
the straw that's breaking the camel's
back for me
too specifically but it just it feels
this is the one that feels too much
and i don't know why for me it hits that
way but this is the one that just feels
like
for a seasonal event you've already got
you can buy everything in the reverse
store now it's
upgraded cards you can
i don't i don't know maybe the upgraded
card is a cheaper way if you do all of
it but
it just feels weird to me i don't love
it
um you know i mean a cup can only hold
so much water before the water starts
pouring over and you might have just
reached that point yeah
yeah
well there is a hot dog eating champ
emote that will be part of it which you
can actually see i'm sure that one will
be entertaining and you've also got the
little old lady beach hat on the
on the ghost there so you got a couple
of those different ones i'm sure lady
that's my wife now man she's only 30
something let's see no that's like
that does not look like a young person's
hat maybe
better a better uh metaphor for bungie's
uh eager uh greed and consumption than a
hot dog eating emote
now we're getting all metaphoric here
and
getting on deep levels
grow fat with strength man yeah the
world of opulence is definitely coming
through
or guardians start walking around they
look like thor from in game when he's
got the belly just gonna hate too much
my wife loved that she
she
you know i'm convinced that once i'm out
of the army she's just gonna get me as
big as possible she loves it that's nice
hey you've been in shape for a good 20
years i'm sure so you're probably due to
just relax a little bit i'm sure your
habits probably once you get too bad but
i would imagine hopefully you'll relax a
little bit on the other side of things
though we do have armor
um this is where the currencies come up
so travis get ready strap in and get
your entertaining arguments coming
uh so solstice armor is gonna work
differently previously you would get
like a blue set you'd do the objectives
of each of the blue set armor when all
of them were done you could upgrade to
the legendary
like low tier do all the objectives on
those upgrade the full set to legendary
high tier which you could take with you
after the event and then if you want him
to glow white you could go do the
certain thing on it cool
it was a little convoluted because he
kind of had to do everything whatever it
was they're changing it now is this
there are some things that are good but
i can't say it's any less simple they
it's
we'll have to see how it is and again
tune in tuesday i will put a guide as
soon as i can wrap my head around
everything in game but you're going to
earn silver leaves
by completing activities throughout the
game
hopefully those are balanced well but
you know people are going to come up
with the fastest farm for those
then you can transform silver leaves
into silver ash by completing the new
activity bonfire bash
now
question one that i have to see how this
works out and i want to get your guys
thoughts on this one
when you transform the leaves into
silver ash do you think you can earn a
whole bunch of leaves
and then go do the bonfire bash once or
do you think you're only going to be
able to cash in a certain number of
leaves at a time and i've killed travis
is he not even there
i can't even get his response because
all i've got see you right now
he's here
it wasn't actually an internet
connection this time he was just it's
just like i can't i can't listen to this
for political reasons he left yeah
well okay so for you question one i
haven't even gots on all the currencies
do you think you're going to be able to
take a lot of silver leaves and put them
into silver ash one time or do you think
it's going to be
multiple times and only a set number of
silver leaves you can turn in at a time
obviously the latter and i think you
know that i
i assume that's how it's going to go
but if you look like silver leaves and
you have a bonfire just throw the leaves
in and you get your ash back
theoretically would make sense though
too but the way the game is yes i expect
the other so that's fine
kindling what
what better metaphor is there
going to another metaphor e
then
this process of them adding
new currencies
them taking something that's full of
life a leaf and turning it into ash
i think that that is exactly what will
be happening to my joy
when i do the solstice event i will be
bringing forward something that was
alive and green and fresh silver and
it'll
silver i mean in this exact example yeah
and i will be leaving with uh nothing
but ashes e that's what i think is going
on
this is a very deep episode we're
getting some deep cuts today
really
really this is just travis gets
depressed during an episode
of the last word and just goes on
melancholy rants
oh man i am like we're jumping back and
forth so i'm trying to like resize
windows as we go it's been an
interesting one
sorry about that no you're good okay so
then
we're also going to get something called
kindling
now this is going to be like a you're
going to set number of this kindling is
going to be completed by the solstice
event you're going to earn that by
completing solstice event challenges so
this will probably be in your little
event card
you will spend kindling to upgrade your
armor so basically what you're going to
do is you're going to do the challenges
and then spin the kindling on the armor
slots that you want
so you can focus into certain ones if
you like as opposed to doing the
objectives that were listed on the armor
so they basically took one thing and
replaced it with another but it's
generally the same idea it seems like
now the only the major positive that i'm
gonna say out of this i will say the
silver lining from the silver leaves and
ash and kindling hey i gotta get one i
gotta get one
the silver ash that you get is going to
allow you to re-roll stats on armor
so you'll go through the seasonal event
challenges you'll get kindling and
you're going to upgrade a slot which is
actually kind of cool this is where i i
would cross my fingers and hope that
this could be something like leveling
where you could just level up a slot and
not have to infuse
because infusion is already annoying
enough
because what you'll do is like if you
get say
a helmet and then you get a couple
others and they're sitting in your vault
and you level up your helmet slot to
three
which would be like the max level
you turn around and any helmets that you
own have on you or future get they're
all tier three you don't have to level
them up again or anything like that
which generally would probably be the
same way as probably once you've
unlocked the class of armor or the tier
of armor in the previous years i think
that's all that would drop but they just
kind of change the way it works
the the thing that i like is the fact
that you're going yeah exactly this is
why i'm going to make a video on tuesday
everybody there's a reason for that so
stay tuned because i'm going to try and
put this all
in video form so i can show you how it
all works as opposed to trying to read
this because i haven't made a video over
this swab today and i was like i'm
reading through this and in my head i
think it makes sense but it's already a
little messy
and if it doesn't quite come through
clear it's a mess until you actually get
to see it then somebody's going to log
in and look at solstice and be like i
don't know how to do anything
so at least there's no new light players
oh kinderguardians good luck starting
the game during solstice of heroes yeah
so basically they say to sum up or tldr
so complete event challenges to earn
kimbling use the kindling to permanently
upgrade your solstice armor stat roll
potential
so basically what you're doing is like
it only gets junk stats it gets medium
stats and now it can have good stats
when you fully upgrade it
you can complete activities to earn
leaves
when you do the bonfire ash you can turn
the leaves into ash and then you can use
the ash to re-roll armor
basically it's a very roundabout way of
saying you actually are going to be able
to get a piece of armor and then re-roll
it as many times as you're willing to
get the silver ash
and if you can focus into a very
specific
stat for example maybe you want really
high strength you can actually focus in
and it's going to be a guaranteed 20
in 20 or higher in that slot so if
you're looking for a build
maybe you're a newer player maybe you
won't like hey i want a high recovery
build or a hunter i need a high mobility
like set you actually will be able to
build yourself a pretty decent set from
this i will say that actually
is something they haven't done with this
event before
now is it a convoluted way to get there
yes but the end game if you put some
time in i could see some benefit to that
for certain people if you've already got
like all the sets of armor you need
this one may not do as much for you
all right so now that i've explained it
crit are you here
i am here sir what are your thoughts on
this because i know travis is gonna have
a whole thing so i got to go to you
first
my completely
neutral
thoughts are that uh it seems to me a
model has
been developed and as in and is in
practice
where
and this happens with vestiges of dread
and bowen essence with nightmare
containment which we are experiencing
this season right
in this case
wings or leaves
would take the place of vestiges of
dread ash taking the place of bound
presence
you
conduct your activities as you normally
would weekly reset hits you do your
strikes you do your gambit you do
crucible you do your dungeon whatever
you acquire vestiges as dread or in this
case leaves
you then participate
in the solstice event
subbing in for nightmare containment you
get your ash you spend it as you need
um whether or not this is the right way
to go about this i can't really say
i will say it does seem to be
a reoccurring pattern and this seems to
be the way that they are content to do
things
right
play the game as you normally would
acquire currency spend in a specific
specific event for additional currency
which is then used for specific rewards
associated with the event so
it is clearly
it's the way they're going um and i
don't see them changing course anytime
soon because it seems to
this is something that has reoccurred
over and over and over again so
yeah okay that's the the high level
summation of the style of event we have
from bungie now you gotta get the travis
hot take
i agree with [ __ ] buff that it is
something that they're doing and likely
won't change but i disagree with him
that i can't say whether it's bad or
good i will gladly say that it is
terrible and that you should stop doing
it because it is
it is a nonsensical system wherein you
have
people chasing a fake thing so they can
earn a separate fake thing so they can
use it to do something else not only is
it confusing and convoluted it's not
fun to earn fake
bucks to spend on things it people
if there's been one through line on what
destiny players enjoy it's when they
complete an activity and that item drops
right in front of them whether it's
popping out of a chest or using a
skeleton key for it or the gallo horn
popping in the upper left-hand corner
that you got it in the loot whatever it
may be they like to see
they want to skip all the steps why am i
getting uh you know bungee bucks that i
can go to a mall and then and then buy
them in the most sterile and unfun way
imaginable and and why are they making
the event more complicated and adding
more currencies when it was first of all
already was kind of complicated but
literally the activities and the stuff
you had to do was on the armor that you
were upgrading they had the technology
to add it there and it had technology
it's other system or they're where
they're just they're making it more
complicated and hard to even understand
like how you progress in the event and i
think we know why they're doing it
they're doing it so that they can add
caps so that they can make it so that
you're you know
if there's one good thing
you know there's going to be caps on all
this crap
and they're gonna that way you can't you
can't complete all of your armor
objectives all at once you have to
choose where to spend your silver
whatever that you're buying and then do
all that
i have one question for you guys
and i want you to think very hard before
you go with the gut answer oh okay i
think
there is any
do you think that there's any chance
it's not a coincidence
that both of these currencies have the
word silver in their title
like another currency in destiny
called silver
oh
my
my answer travis is that i suppose when
we think about the tree of silver wings
was it back in
yeah
season of arrivals that's what they're
going for but
any chance you're gonna be able to turn
silver into silver leaves or ash
oh god i hope you're wrong
i hope i'm wrong i don't think you're
going to be able to do that
because again that gets into buying
oh yeah because we all know bungie's
really afraid of charging their players
for things they've they've been so i'm
not saying that but i'm just saying you
would literally be paying for stat
rerolls at that point
and i don't think they would they've
they technically haven't crossed that
line yet
well
not 100 percent true they charge you for
ghosts
and sparrows that do have gameplay
impact but you can get one with the same
functionality
in the past you had to get them through
eververse only and you could
they added where now you can put mods
and stuff but there were like xp boosts
and stuff so they've done it in the past
and i thought that they were pulling
away from it
but
i don't know man i'm not so sure now
i have my doubts that's all i'm gonna
say
it does seem to be creeping into a weird
territory i mean the whole the upgrade
card as i already said was kind of a
weird feeling for me i mean that's just
one of those like you get this weird
vibe like there's going to be a solstice
upgrade card
that's that i you and then there's going
to be a festival of the lost upgrade
card that you can do
but then you're also going to be able to
buy the armor at eververse i'm like what
if the there was a ticket that i could
earn the armor from the card but then
you gotta buy it i don't know it's as
you've already said it there's too much
going on with too many ways to spend
money
most all of them generally do tend to be
for cosmetics this i don't think will
involve actual silver which is
across our fingers i hope not
um and i don't expect that if they did
that they would get a lot of flack
really quickly
um
it's just one of those things
for certain
i was just gonna say for certain players
being able to build a set around a stat
of armor that you may not have had been
able to focus into before or now with
resilience having more of like a damage
mitigation thing i know people are
looking to try and get into that or get
stability or whatever
um flinch and those type of things
certain people may be trying to get a
stat they didn't have before so this is
a way to actually try and
like re-roll and focus armor which is
something we haven't been able to do in
a very long time since glass needles
so it is nice to see
that as an option the grind to get there
is going to be interesting but
overall that's like the silver lining
for me of the event it it feels weird
with the upgrade card but if i can earn
armor that i can reroll stats and be
like eventually be like okay re-roll
re-roll all right i got a cool headpiece
let me use that one i'm good and it's
like if you wanted to build one or two
sets of armor from this you could
but as i said if you don't need to do
anything like that this whole thing is
probably just going to feel
probably not necessary for some people
veterans especially
so something to support my concept or my
idea that you know silver uh leaves
silver
tree right they call it a paracausal
bonfire and the tree was pericausal in
nature
that is true if i remember correctly so
that's the only thing i can offer in
support of my of my point hey it's
better it's it's something honestly i
don't think they would actually make it
real silver because that would
you would see some very good flack about
that one but i'm just saying i i tend to
agree but i'm just saying it's not off
the table given what we know and also i
regardless regardless of whether silver
has any in interplay with silver leaves
or silver ash
it is even more confusing if you're a
new light and you're looking at silver
leaves and silver ash i would not i
would not blame anyone for thinking oh
i'll pay 20 bucks for silver that'll
probably help me progress in this silver
based activity i'm doing so
it's all of it is it just adds another
layer of complexity regardless and i
just i hate the way they do currencies
it's such a pointless arbitrary
treadmill that they could just simplify
like every other looter shooter does
no looter shooter does this man i just
got done reviewing outriders worldslayer
that is a game where you get your drops
right either from enemies or from loot
chests it feels good when you get loot
destiny is so in its head with like this
how how do we create the perfect
treadmill for players to run on that i
think they forgotten the beautiful
simplicity and killing something and
getting a cool drop
that used to be how we got everything
yeah
i mean that's
i guess
you know the double-edged sword of
bungie has been able to be successful
build up a studio grow themselves
unfortunately some of it has come at the
implementation of eververse and the
expansions and the seasons and some of
these things that we have disagreements
with and how they monetize
the game that we play it's like
and then there's a point like what is
too far how deep do your pockets really
need to get
or what else is it going towards the
netties 160 million or whatever it was i
always forget that number but it was
like 100 million dollars at least
was you know put in and now we figure
out what that's going to is going to be
something separate
but it does get to a point to where how
many times do
do we need to have a question of like
what is too far in the monetization when
you said you turn our new play out
writers
but then you see like the success of
outriders
it came flash in the pan there was a lot
of technical difficulties because
honestly if that game came out
technically polished the first time
it actually would have done very well it
was the technical difficulties deleted
inventories cog couldn't log in for a
month
like you had some major issues that
burned that one but if you do make a
good game
like they mostly did
then it can do well but again to manage
and pay for a live service
things apparently get very very
expensive and these seem to be some of
the ways that they try and pay for it
but yeah i do feel as they build out the
studio they have more artists and other
things at some point
give me something i can earn in the game
that's equivalent you can have cool
things here
and you can have equivalent things that
you can buy but at some point i want to
see a little more equality between those
two the dungeon this season was an
example with the armor i feel like that
armor from everest should have been in
there the season pass wherever it was
i also think players get a little too
[Music]
uh empathetic with bungie which sounds
like a weird thing to say but like
i i don't think that you should always
be worried about like well they're
running a business they have to keep
money like that's their problem right
your problem is if you're judging them
just saying like does this feels a good
experience as a player do i feel like
i'm getting my money's worth and that
i'm being treated fairly you should
always be looking at things from that
and you should try to blind yourself in
my opinion to how bungie is making a
buck
they're gonna be fine i guarantee you
they just got acquired they're
they're gonna be okay but i don't think
that that it's our responsibility as
players to put ourselves in their shoes
and go oh but you know they've got bills
to pay and you know nancy just got
promoted and she's getting you know a
10k more a year and i just i don't
that's not our job as players i think
our job is to say look at what we're
getting look at how we're being treated
look at how confusing or simple the
system is and ask yourself does this
does this jive with the industry
standard does this make me feel like my
time and investment is being respected
my dollar is being respected and if the
answer is no then who cares
you know you know how bungie is paying
its bills or what their their income and
and uh expenses are that's not your
problem unless you unless you work in
finance for bungie in which case
you know i'd love to have you on the
show and talk about what your what your
problems are uh i don't think that
that's something you should do that's a
guest i don't see us getting
yeah i don't see the community team
blessing off on that appearance yeah can
we get the cfo to join us on the show
and we want to break down these
monetization models and really
understand
where are our bungee bucks going and how
do we get more bungee bucks
i see dylan greenlighting that one
yeah no the press would be like nope
delete that email
in fair point yeah that's not a press
trained person or anything
but no i mean i completely agree and
that's why i said for me this is the
first time whatever you said the cup got
full it's like for me this is the time
it's like the event card just feels
feels weird feels odd feels a bit much
we already do as you said
i mean i bought the deluxe edition
with the 30th anniversary so i spent 100
bucks on the year of destiny
cool
i get the dungeons but yeah you have a
new player come in they buy the season
and they don't get the dungeon with it
well can they go by the deluxe edition
okay but the deluxe edition has a season
that some of it will be there but it
will go away eventually so depending on
when they buy the deluxe edition to get
these things
how long are those gonna stick around
next year being as the dungeons tend to
stay in the game
but on the other side the seasonal
content
does not
when we think of the duality dungeon
next year how is somebody going to turn
around and play the duality dungeon and
season 19
in lightfall
are they gonna just have to buy the year
five dungeon key
in lightfall even though that stuff's
back here and maybe on a rotating
pinnacle
thing where it comes up for a pinnacle
drop from the final boss once every six
weeks
is that what you're really gonna have to
do next here like i mean i'm asking you
guys a legitimate question do you think
that's what it would take
i'm trying to add up how much money
you'd have to pay to get a full year of
destiny
if you wanted everything in the game i
mean you can do 80 bucks right now 80
bucks would buy you which queen and
everything for this year that's what it
was a 30 bucks
what about the events books that they're
selling now oh i mean in theory there's
four events i think because you got
solstice
uh you got festival of the lost you got
the donning and i'm forgetting one which
i feel like we just went through what
was the event last season a year yeah so
120 bucks for
all the event cards as well as the
expansion and the four seasons if that
expansion deluxe edition say includes
the
dungeons
yeah 120 bucks would be event cards and
then the deluxe edition with the
expansion seasons and dungeons
because my understanding is for the
obviously anybody can take part in the
seasons but if you want a treadmill of
things to earn during those
those events
those uh seasonal events even to get on
the treadmill you have to pay the 10
bucks right
is that my understanding correct you can
so the way the event tickets work is
you'll earn the event tickets all the
way through
the event if you want to choose to
upgrade your card you can wait till the
last day
if you've earned all the tickets that
you feel like you want to earn
buy the upgrade and turn on all your
tickets so you can wait to see how many
tickets you get to figure out if it's
worth it for you which is something i
recommended in my video but
yes
yeah you don't get anything on that
reward treadmill until you pay the money
though the upgraded one correct yeah you
get nothing from that until you pay it
terrible idea
frankly
do you think in lightfall
a new player is going to have to buy a
dungeon key to go play duality
uh
gosh i
is he pondering are you there at a
really unfortunate time yeah he's
really deep in thought right now i'll
give mine and i think the answer is yes
because the dungeon key is a separate
transaction right now
it's gonna sit out there in the store
and it's just probably going to stay
there and it's going to be duality and
whatever season 19 dungeon is going to
be
that's how you're going to get access to
them in lightfall and you won't have
access to them if you don't buy that key
that's correct i was like i feel now
what it should be
is
say light falls 40 bucks
say the deluxe edition is 80.
do you want to own all previous content
20 more dollars
just make it one flat fee and wrap
everything else in a bow
what about three i mean that would be
the optimal one but if they feel like
they need to charge for
you know all of the buying the base game
as well that's like your base game
purchase or something like that i think
get all the old stuff
i think it hurts bungie to not make all
the old stuff free because then they
managed to se even if they do manage to
sell a new user on destiny they
immediately have to explain all the
stuff that they can't do and it becomes
i think it's like more of a burden on
them than it is
on
on us
you know what i mean like
i mean i'm not arguing i think it should
be but kurt puff's back okay so the best
timing you you were very deep in
thoughts and now you're back
yes what is your what are your thoughts
on that question since you probably
heard mine
when i buy lightfall
i should get everything that happened up
to life all as well that is still in the
game yep i'm i agree
but i just do you think it will work
that way that's the question no okay
we agree on both sides we don't think
it's going to work that way but we think
it should
yes yeah
i actually i'm even more extreme than
you guys i don't think you should have
to buy lightfall
i think at this point the season passes
and the microtransactions and the
transmog and all the stuff they're doing
with the events books now that you're
getting i think that their model does
not match the industry standard at all
if you look at live service games like
fortnight which you don't have to buy
ever right they're free to play warzone
like all these games and a lot of those
games have a lot of content now
obviously destiny we hold it up on a bit
of a pedestal because it's got such high
quality content but at this point they
have enough revenue sources and they're
no longer an indie company that's doing
their own publishing and all those other
problems right they're about to about to
be nested in this large corporation i
don't think it makes sense for them to
be charging for expansions at all and i
think that if they didn't charge for
expansions and they made all that base
content free and just charged for the
special stuff it would actually help
them because it removes a bunch of
barriers of entry from getting people to
start playing your game and to keep
playing it and to not fall off and it
stops the bleeding that i feel has been
happening for a couple years now where
it becomes their their player base is
fragmented four different ways now for
all these people that do or don't know
all this different content and i don't i
don't think that puts them in his
position for success them being bungie
or the players for that matter so i just
think that lightfall should be a free
expansion
and that they should if they're gonna
cont they need to choose one either you
charge me a hundred bucks for that year
of destiny or you charge me nothing and
you make all your money when i buy your
season passes and your microtransactions
and all that stuff but they should not
be selling the main content if they have
the microtransaction model they have it
just doesn't make sense no other game
has it
none
i'm i'm not arguing
i i mean
realistically from their end
i don't see them doing a free expansion
because those expansions are larger
influxes
uh in the deluxe editions as well but i
am to the point to where
if i tell a friend hey do you want to
jump into lightfall especially because
you keep taking stuff away
and then you now you know you have
limited time like somebody goes to play
final fantasy 14 they can start at a
realm reborn and go
it might take them 400 hours to get
through it all but technically it's
there you can't even do that in this
game
so i think there's the point as you said
simplification for the player base on
fragmentation of the player base
lightfall and forward costing some money
whatever they're gonna do anything
before that free
i mean it's gotta be like there's no
it just
it burns too many people as you said
you've started the bleeding and they're
not helping new players fill in the
holes enough there's got to be a point
in this population is just getting
smaller and smaller
and and if you try and milk the small
you're only going to get you can't get
blood out of a stone at some point it's
just not going to happen
that's kind of where i'm at on that one
and it is
yeah i will be very curious to get cogs
take next week because
i know he's not here for this one but
just to see how this is
how this is how he's taken i guess just
another micro another
whatever it may be
but yeah when it comes to the twab
uh they do have the foundation update
going on always a good thing all their
fundraiser incentives are going on and
he said mudkip was doing that so if you
are a fundraiser and you do 2500 or 5000
you get some cool emblems if you are a
donator you can get the new seven of
seven emblem uh looks like kind of a
seventh column
cool looking rework to it and then also
the if you do a hundred bucks it's 50
for the seven to seven hundred bucks for
the heart of hearts emblem yep i think
every heart of heart emblem they've done
in destiny 2 it looks like five of them
uh i mean all this stuff is going to
improving children's health and
well-being uplifting the voices and
rights of the individuals and
communities and providing humanitarian
aid for those in times of crisis as they
always do their fundraising efforts are
fantastic
and they also kind of go for a little
bit for the over 165 000 guardians have
found their loyal companion
with the loyal companion emote
you go watch that story about the
make-a-wish kid christian
uh and his dog your dog lover you're
screwed grab a kleenex you're gonna cry
it's
it got me dude i was watching that and
it just
could not help it
and then they got the little plushy dog
in there it kind of it's a german
shepherd looks like once i don't know
like it's not quite a husky but it's
close enough i still might end up
getting it um
but yeah that one
that one was rough for a dog person him
and everything else was like that was
rough but yeah bungie foundation is
always doing fantastic stuff so check
that one out some cool emotes and stuff
and good causes that they go to
uh but outside of that the patch next
week we will actually have three hours
of downtime three hours and 15 minutes
so actually from
6 45 a.m pacific until 10 a.m pacific
it'll be down so a longer downtime than
we've had in a while actually um outside
of like it's great for me because that's
like 3 45 to
you know oh yeah you'll be uh you can
sleep a little more you can sleep a
little bit there you go
yeah that is something i will have to
get used to going to the east coast
going from being three hours behind pst
to being uh
what three hours ahead three hours at
three hours ahead yeah so
that'll be a fun adjustment
yeah that'll take you a little bit for a
minute
it's gonna be gonna be a rough first
week if it's a six hour like permanent
jet lag for a minute i would say
so
the
the multiple trips across both oceans
for the military have kind of cured me
of that i just if i go to sleep that
night i wake up i'm fine i'm adjusted
i'm set nice
yeah i haven't gone far enough that it's
hit me like i haven't gone to
europe or
you know the asia side of things to
where it's like a far enough adjustment
i went to hawaii and it was
five hours from here
yeah um
and then
oh because i'm in dallas and it was we
talked to like the concierge like hey
what should we do in the morning and
they're like oh there's this like
surfing thing like six in the morning
like are we gonna be tired she's like no
you're gonna be awake
because our body clock was gonna be off
and sure enough like we got up for that
one but yeah like that one time kind of
worked out but i could assume it would
be pretty what pretty bad
yeah
um i got a funny story one day about a
typo got me sent to thailand and back 34
hours of straight flying
how many hours
34 hours of straight flying a typo and
an email got me
sorry sorry for another time god
how's that out
what how you got to tell us now
remember i mentioned earlier uh before
the show that you know my job has a
similar job in the military and the
terms are used synonymously the names
for both jobs okay
that resulted in me getting sent when
they wanted somebody else so they kicked
me as soon as i landed in bangkok
they're like we didn't want you what are
you doing here get out of here
and then that got me sent on a plane uh
right back from bangkok to seattle
bam
so
yeah that's rough
you were probably you're like can i
sleep for a minute when you get back
home it's like
hopefully got a chance to recover
now the office wanted me back in to go
over what happened right after i got
back home even though my wife and child
both of the flu when i left too
well that was a very expensive typo that
got written off as
probably a very expensive toilet seat or
whatever the joke is or something like
that so
okay sorry enough about that sorry no no
that's see random stories we don't hear
about i just you know
boring civilian life we don't get to
accidentally travel to thailand on
on a whim so
but my daughter a little minnie mouse
doll though i'm sure it was like
licensed i'm sure disney was well aware
of that
oh yeah i'm sure that was 100 legit
merchandise
yeah
but yeah it is a quieter time in destiny
so i mean if you're working through
backlog playing some other things
putting 2 000 hours into xenoblade
chronicles 3. make sure i say that right
i'm sorry like xenophage like comes out
of my mouth a lot more than xenoblade so
forgive me yeah
uh it's not like that uh that game has a
you know super passionate audience or
anything that you don't have to worry
about reacting
and nobody even cares yeah
okay so here's a question when you put
because a lot of the ign reviews are
pretty condensed
yours might be
not a hair longer but yours like you
know eight nine ten minutes i might have
seen one
um i think the loop mancer one today was
probably about eight minutes
when you have a game of that link does
it
necessitate much like any longer review
or is your goal always to still be able
to tell your review even if it's a 200
hour game
in that 10-ish minute window
yeah i'm someone who
doesn't really like the skill-up model
just because i feel like if you can't
put the overview and the thoughts of
what is helpful to a player who's coming
at it from maybe not knowing much about
the game then you're sort of asking them
to do a lot of work when you could
you're supposed to do the work for them
right you're supposed to summarize
you're supposed to make the review
digestible and not make them watch an
hour long video to understand what you
think
but i also think that you know tweeting
a review is
not really great practice either because
it just is too much of a summary for me
so typically i try to end between like
1500 to 2500 words somewhere around
there um and i'm a pretty i'm a pretty
uh
snappy writer i tend to squeeze my
thoughts into fewer sentences rather
than more i don't really drag on despite
what i do when i talk i drag on when i
talk and then when i write i make it uh
very short
i'm long-winded for sure
yeah i'm long-winded when i talk but
when i write i'm really succinct uh so
uh
yeah i think um
to better best serve the player who's
wondering if this game is worth their
time it won't be substantially longer
that said
my review is as long as i have something
to say and so if a game being really
long means that i have a lot to say
about it it will probably be longer i
don't know if that's the case with
xenoblade i think uh
xenoblade is long because it's a jrpg
that wants you to wants to make you feel
like you're on an epic journey and wants
to make you feel like you know the party
in your the people and the characters in
your party like really well like you're
like best friends with them by the end
of the the game and so
um
i uh
somebody in the context of making fun of
me for talking too much
yeah to answer your question i think
it'll probably be about the same even
though i've spent you know now over 100
hours playing the game at this point so
yeah
i mean that's kind of one of those like
i appreciate both i guess i'm as a
consumer of reviews and stuff like that
i do
tend to watch both i'll watch the acg's
because he's usually
somewhere between an ign and a skill up
scale ups will be on the longer end but
i'll get more
more of some of the detail and
especially for somebody like that if
i've got like
something like i'm
walking the dog or something like that
and it's like i just his have been good
if it's one where the visuals might
spoil me but he can do a lot with words
those are actually kind of a good one
for him to like go into some of the
nitty-gritty or the details about things
and kind of feel some time but on the
other side if you're like all right i
need like less than 10 minutes is this
game good or not
stopping ign you guys are
very specifically built for that so it
is one of those that
but as you said it's like it is your job
to summarize
but there i was like i would just wonder
it's like his you know destiny one was
like an hour long
and it was like
but part like i could see a destiny
review
like for
even you i know is gonna be succinct but
there's so many different depending on
where you're coming from and stuff like
that um
i can see the dusty one being longer but
also i can see like but you appreciate
when you can still consolidate it that
much so it is it's a talent to be able
to shrink it down
yeah i i i to be clear i understand
where skill is coming from and i think
there's room for both i even think
there's room for a tweet review for
somebody who really doesn't have time
and if it's a maybe give me an it's just
a number
yeah just a number right like that ign
kind of does that with our summary and
our number right at the end but uh i i
it to me it's more just that like
i'm probably shooting for a different
type of reader slash viewer than a
skillup is a skill up once his audience
comes because they like those deep dives
and they probably want to hear you know
him talk forever and they would be upset
if he did just a 20 minute video
uh i think the ign viewer is is
literally it it's like the everyman
gamer they're they probably get dive
deep into certain games but other games
they're wondering if it's worth the time
and they're using our site to navigate
the the the uh the landscape and so it's
a very different type of reader i think
like this is something you probably
can't say is it's like confidential
whatever i would be very curious your
analytics of if you click on a review
and then how like to know the scroll to
the number
[Laughter]
like what is that
you're like oh 2500 words no i read the
the 12 or like maybe 40 words in the red
next to the number and i'm out like i
can only imagine yeah that track
analytics
inside is pretty funny because if you
have like a an editor account on our
site it adds this bar to the bottom to
the top of every page that shows
analytic data at a glance and one of the
things it has is
view viewers
unique viewers versus
engaged viewers and it tells you what
the breakdown is percentage-wise and uh
you can and then it will tell you like
how many are engaged in this article
versus the average article that week or
that month and so there's a lot of like
interesting analytic things where you
know
uh
whether it's resonating with people or
if people are just commenting to scroll
down to the bottom and make a mean
comment or say something or or just look
at the review score but uh typically if
they want to know the score they
actually don't click on the article they
just read the summary and they look at
the number of the score
you guys have started to do that
actually yeah that wasn't always there
so that's probably been
yeah i guess a good and a bad it's a
better better idea but yeah the the i
would say the average ign reviewer at
least on my stuff because i only really
check my articles i just want to know
like how people are engaging are they
they're pretty engaged
they're pretty good what's the uh what's
the old saying if i had more time i'd
have written a shorter letter
right
that is 100 sure you have to work like
twice as hard to get something like more
sustained so
yeah i i would agree with that
philosophy 100 percent you know the
number of times i look at my review
scripts and then i just after i do a
control f for the word that
and 90 of the time i delete yes
yeah i got i got i got pretty good at uh
cliffing that one out i actually have
it's funny that we're talking about this
because i uh
i'm doing a another show tonight where
we're talking about review philosophies
it's like a long-form thing so this is
kind of like pre-gaming right now
but i actually challenge myself and you
can read any of my reviews and try to
catch me on this but i try to not
include even one sentence in any of my
reviews that does not contain an opinion
interesting
every sentence has to have opinion in it
because my philosophy is a review is
your opinion you're just trying to get
to the meat of is this game good or bad
what about it did you like what about it
didn't you like and if you're spending a
lot of time explaining what the game is
without providing opinion context you're
sort of wasting time with the review and
so i try to challenge myself to not even
have one sentence without opinions and
if you read it i challenge you i i'm
pretty good about this i'm sure a few
have slipped in over the years but i'm
pretty good about literally never
including a sentence that doesn't have
some kind of opinionated statement or
language to it well i steal that yeah
that's not bad
uh thank you zeno for these two dollar
super chats um thank you for your
service crit buff so i appreciate it oh
thank you xeno i appreciate that
absolutely uh as we still have you
connected want to give you a chance to
wrap up tell everybody where you can
find where you can be found what you're
doing
um you know all that type of stuff
basically the floor is yours
thank you very much uh so gentlemen
again thank you for having me on you can
find me on youtube just do a search for
kripa if you'll find the channel uh i'm
on twitter where i'm apparently a bit of
a lightning rod so you know have fun
with that
same call sign
definitely yeah go check out his twitter
give him a follow give him some support
some positivity and there's never a bad
thing because twitter has its moments
but definitely also go check out his
youtube videos very thought out reviews
you know a thousand kills happened
before that review but he spent some
time with it so it's more than just
looking at uh
perk options he's got a real opinion
because he put in the work so definitely
check him out thank you very much kurt
buff for joining us tonight
very appreciated uh travis what about
you
just more time in xenoblade and see if
you can get iron lord right
uh yeah so i i did a preview of
xenoblade that came out last week uh
covering the combat system and what i
think about it so far
um until
as for now that's all i'll be able to
talk about it until um january 20 of
january july 26th when uh my review
comes out uh which should be uh pretty
uh contentious people have very strong
feelings about the game myself included
um and then uh i'm also previewing a
game called roller drum uh that should
also live that same morning july 26th oh
wonderful time gotta love that
um i'm also reviewing a game oh i can't
talk about that one actually has not
been announced uh but i'm i'm previewing
another game uh that's gonna get
announced uh later this month um and
yeah i'm gonna be on a show talking
about review philosophy and
what makes a good review with ainsley
bowden on the season gaming youtube i
don't know if it's going to be live
stream but that's literally happening
right after this i'm hopping from this
column to that one and so
we should be on at seven pacific so an
hour from now at the latest um yeah so
up on that if you want to and then uh
you can also find me sunday mornings on
bitcast
uh where i've talked to
a lawyer named hogue uh ainsley bowden
himself
and the inspiration for the scarecrow uh
dan rodriguez so
yeah you can catch me there every sunday
if you'd like
that's me
awesome uh yeah again crit thank you for
your service uh glad you get to kind of
you're as you said you're in the
twilight of your service so you can
kind of get back into the civilian light
and hopefully back to some better
internet um
i mean hey if nothing else is if this is
what you're dealing with gaming you got
to have some lag bots all over the place
so
you can
everybody probably thinks you're
cheating and finally you'll be able to
call it call the others out if they are
so
i was cheating my trials katie would be
better and people couldn't try to uh
stat shame you with it
yeah i was like who cares i was like i'm
sure my katie is trash as well but i
don't do a whole lot but
if you have fun playing the game it's
fine nobody nobody should care that much
no they shouldn't but they do oh yeah of
course
um but yeah that for me i did actually
wrap up both of those kind of side games
i was working on i'm trying to decide
between have a nice death
um the opening to have a nice death i
actually watched a youtube video just
like i was doing one thing and watch the
opening that opening is so stylistically
awesome and looks fun i may have to play
that one but i'm also debating on loot
mancer since it just dropped actually
just to get a little i'm trying to put a
couple smaller indie titles before i
jump into something like horizon because
that's definitely going to be another
like 50 60 hour stream set so that'll be
a bit but yeah cog should be back next
week also next week if you guys are this
far into the show might as well tell you
who's coming we've got uh i resolute
irresolute i'm probably saying that
wrong uh but he will be
yes actually good artist good player so
should be a fun chat and then on the
28th
give you guys a little preview we got
ads to cross coming on
on the 28th
that one should be fun uh and then a
little preview i'm just going to say i'm
fast i got stadia time legionless tv
professor broman
big daddy tiege
and kyt kucha uh from the massive
breakdown so we've got
some good guests coming up so yeah i've
got us lined up basically through
september first stacked so all star
roster e congrats i i'm doing the
producer thing over here so i'm trying
my best
doing a good job um but yes again thank
you all for chat for being here this was
a fun one thank you for rolling with the
technical difficulties but crit thank
you for taking time out of your vacation
and leave to chat with us we very much
appreciate it and again very much thank
you for your service
as we wrap up this show as always it is
july 14th episode number 206 and even
though cog is not here i know he's doing
it in spirit it has
been the last word